- You can't really call me a
crazy cat lady; I'm obsessive.
I would rather have 800
cats than another man.
I don't need a man in my life.
Been there, done that,
bought the t-shirt, no.
Kitty, kitty, kitty, kitty, kitty, kitty.
Floyd, come on, Cricket.
(light upbeat music)
This is called the Cat House on the Kings.
It's a 12 acre, no cage, no kill,
sanctuary, rescue adoption center,
and we also do a a lot
of spays and newters.
(cat meowing)
Oh, come here Cricket.
Come on.
We have close to 800 adults
and 300 kittens
on the property as we speak.
(kitten meowing)
(bright upbeat music)
It wasn't like I planned,
"Hey, I think I'll have
"a thousand cats, what a novel idea."
It wasn't like that.
I thought, well, there's always room for more,
they're gonna kill this one.
We have way too many cats.
So this, this was my house.
You can see that it's an
extremely large house.
- [Interviewer] So you
had to give up your home
for these cats?
- I tried for about 16
years to make it work
but it wasn't okay having
60 something in my bedroom.
One night they threw up in my
ear and that was when I moved.
All 4,200 square feet is theirs,
that's why we call it the Cat House.
We have saved over
28,000 cats in 24 years.
We have a staff now of about 45.
You have to be very on top of the job
because you have a lot of cats
that your responsible for.
No point in rescuing
'em and taking them in
if you can't take care of them.
You know this is not normal,
people after a while would say,
"Well, you know, I think
I've done this enough,
"I think I'll go have a life
now, I think I'll go travel."
Nope, not me!
Daphne, look this way.
Daph!
Come on, I want you to be on TV.
(bright upbeat music)